These are 3 tips if you want to stop eating animals
in 2 024 1 if you don't know where to start,
the easiest way is to adapt your favorite foods.
For example,
if 1 of your favorite foods is burrito,
instead of adding meat,
what you can do is replace it with legumes.
It is still very good
and in this way
your taste buds are adapting to this change.
2 prepare everything in advance,
when we are hungry or in a hurry,
the first thing we do
is to take anything from the fridge,
so make yourself
1 favor in the future
and always have food or snacks on hand.
3 even though you were often asked,
don't worry too much about protein.
Contrary to popular belief,
not only meat has protein,
there are 1 lot of plant foods that are excellent
sources such as legumes,
tofu,
Seitán,
Teme,
nuts.
If you want to discover new vegan recipes,
take 1 look at my profile and follow me